Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Ciro Gomez
Las abejas son criaturas
fascinantes por varias razones:
por su ética de trabajo increíble,
por el jarabe dulce azucarado que producen
y por su compleja estructura social.
Pero otra razón es que
las abejas son, de hecho,
excelentes matemáticas.
Los científicos afirman que estos pequeños
insectos pueden calcular ángulos,
e incluso comprender
la redondez de la Tierra.
Pero hay un ingenio particular
matemático-apícola
detrás del aspecto más importante de
la vida de las abejas: la colmena.
Como los humanos, las abejas necesitan alimentos
y refugio para mantenerse con vida.
La colmena no es solo
el hogar de las abejas,
sino que funciona como lugar
para guardar su miel.
Como es clave para su supervivencia,
las abejas tienen que perfeccionar
el diseño arquitectónico de la colmena.
Si examinamos un trozo de panal,
veremos que está construido
de celdas compactas hexagonales,
o sea, de 6 lados.
De todos los diseños posibles,
¿por qué eligieron este las abejas?
Para entenderlo, hay que
pensar como abeja.
Las abejas necesitan un lugar seguro
para que viva la colonia.
Del mismo modo, es necesario
que haya un lugar
donde poder almacenar y macerar
el néctar de manera adecuada
hasta que se convierta en miel.
Por eso necesitan gran
eficiencia de espacio.
Una buena solución es construir pequeñas
unidades de almacenamiento, o celdas,
suficientemente grandes como
para que quepa una abeja,
que también puedan funcionar
como contenedores de néctar:
los frascos de miel de las abejas.
Lo siguiente es decidir de qué
están hechas las pequeñas celdas.
Las abejas no tienen picos
ni brazos para recoger cosas,
pero pueden producir cera.
Pero producirla
lleva un arduo trabajo.
Las abejas tienen que
consumir 240 g de miel
para producir solo 30 g de cera.
Por eso no quieren desperdiciarla.
Necesitan un diseño que
les permite almacenar
la mayor cantidad posible de miel
usando la menor cantidad de cera.
¿Qué forma permite eso?
Supongamos por un minuto
que las abejas tuviesen
que ir a la facultad de arquitectura
a tomar clases de matemática.
Supongamos que le preguntaran
al profesor de geometría:
"¿Qué forma nos daría el mayor espacio
para almacenar nuestra miel
pero que requiera la menor
cantidad de cera?"
El profesor de geometría respondería:
"La forma que buscan es el círculo".
Dejamos que las abejas vuelvan
a la construcción de prueba
a construir su colmena
de celdas circulares.
Pasado un tiempo, algunas advertirán
un problema de diseño:
hay pequeñas hendijas entre las celdas.
"¡Ni siquiera cabemos!
¡Es un desperdicio de espacio!"
podrían pensar.
Ignorando la lección de geometría,
y tomando cartas en el asunto,
las abejas vuelven al tablero de dibujo
para repensar el diseño de su colmena.
Una sugiere triángulos:
"Podemos usar triángulos. ¡Miren!
Encajan perfectamente".
Otra sugiere cuadrados.
Finalmente, interviene
una tercera y dice:
"Los pentágonos parecen no funcionar,
pero los hexágonos sí!"
Queremos la forma que use
la menor cantidad de cera
y pueda almacenar
la mayor cantidad de miel.
Sí, pienso que es el hexágono".
"¿Por qué?"
"Se parece más a un círculo
que las otras".
"Pero, ¿cómo saberlo
a ciencia cierta?"
Para averiguarlo, los laboriosos
insectos arquitectos
calcularon las áreas del triángulo,
el cuadrado y el hexágono
y encontraron que
el hexágono era, de hecho,
la forma que les daba el mayor
espacio de almacenamiento.
Estuvieron de acuerdo en un tamaño ideal
y volvieron al trabajo.
La colmena eficiente en espacio que
es marca registrada de una abeja hoy,
probablemente sea resultado
de esta prueba y error,
pero en grandes períodos
de historia evolutiva.
Sin embargo, dio sus frutos.
Miren de reojo cualquier colmena,
con gafas de protección
y máscara, por supuesto,
y verán el resultado final:
una colmena compacta y hermosa
que sería el orgullo de diseño
de cualquier arquitecto.